- Welcome to the show.
Had y'all ever met before?
- No.
- No, we have not.
- [Kelly] All right, well
you have now, besties.
- Yes, fun.
- I have to lead with this,
cause I was very against
a sequel to Hocus Pocus.
I was like, "Why?"
- [Whitney] You were not alone,
you're not alone in that.
- And then, and then I loved it
more than the first one. (audience cheers)
It was so good.
- Thank you.
- You did such a great job.
I love that we're speaking
about generational kind
of things and that's what
was happening in Hocus Poc...
I thought it was so clever,
it was so well done.
It was... cause it's
just like such a classic,
you know at Christmas, not Christmas.
Well at my house.
At Halloween I was just like,
"oh man what are they gonna do?"
It was so good.
Was it cool to work with-
- Thank you.
- the OG's? You know, Sarah and Kathy Bet.
Was that cool?
- [Whitney] Definitely.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Whitney] I think cool
is an understatement.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think, thinking about,
you know, getting to set
and like meeting all these people
that you've heard so much about
and expecting them to be like, you know
really cool and really nice.
And then them actually being the coolest.
- Doesn't always happen.
- [Whitney] Exactly.
- Yeah.
- So you hear the stories
and then you get there and
I was like, no, it's just...
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- They were amazing. Yeah.
- I loved it, I thought it was so clever.
I just had to lead with that.
But now you're on Gossip Girl.
This is, so this is the
new like Gossip Girl.
So what's new this season?
- Well if you enjoyed the
first season, the first season
was kind of like a good warmup.
You know just really teasing some things.
- Oh, app or TV.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I think this season really
lives up to its predecessor.
- [Kelly] Good tease, okay.
- [Whitney] I think it
gets, it gets more dramatic.
Is that me?
- [Kelly] Yes, that's you.
- [Whitney] Oh my God. That's me, wow.
No, it gets 10 times better
and worse and more devious
than the first season.
And there's some crazy, crazy
relationships that happen
that I don't know if everybody
is gonna see coming, but...
- Oh my gosh, you're really
good at teasing this.
- I'm trying not to say anything.
- I know, but no, I'm
saying it's a good job.
Now I'm like dying to know. Yeah.
- I mean you gotta tune in.
- All right, fine.
So like, Andie, I find this crazy.
We did not plan this, we did not know.
But you also worked at a fast
food place with your mom.
- I did.
- [Kelly] This is-
- I know, how crazy is that?
- That's not, not, I don't
know anybody else's done that.
And now both of you showed up here today
and we found this out.
- Yeah. Where did you work?
- McDonald's.
- Wendy's.
- [Kelly] Wendy's (audience laughs) yeah.
Competitors. Okay.
What was, what was your
experience like doing that?
- Well, I think I was really
young and I wanted a job
cause my mom was just
like, always raised us
to be super hustlers
and just wanted to work
at a really young age.
And so I really wanted to, to
help out and to have a job.
And she vouched for me with
her manager at the Wendy's
by my high school.
I hadn't gone to high school yet
but I worked there for about two weeks.
I went from a drive-through
and then I worked my way into the kitchen,
which then I left when I booked a movie.
- [Kelly] When they bumped you into there?
- Yeah. Yep.
It was a really stressful,
stressful time in the kitchen.
It gets really hot and people yell and-
- Oh.
- A sandwich is not as
easy as it looks to make.
- What was your experience
like at McDonald's?
Was it hard like that?
- Oh no, I just was
reflected on something crazy
I did once when I was working there.
- Wait, I wanna know.
- [Andie] Okay.
- [Whitney] Tell me please.
- All right, it makes me sound terrible.
I promise you-
- I love your stories.
(Kelly and Whitney laughs)
- It was the only time
I've ever done this.
You may not believe it,
but it is the truth.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I smoked some hash.
- [Kelly] Just once? (everyone laughs)
- What?
- And I went to work stoned,
but this is, I'm old.
So we had to count back change.
This is before they
counted it back for ya.
- [Kelly] You had to do it.
- And I had to count
back the change myself.
- You're stoned.
- And I was so stoned.
It was just unbelievable,
the concentration it took, (all laughing)
to give some, to give
people back the right amount
of money was unbelievable.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And I still can't believe
it that I pulled it off.
I don't know.
I was like, what are they
gonna find the end of the day?
You know, it's like I did it though.
- Oh my God, and your first time.
That has to be like, that's
a pretty big experience.
- [Andie] Yes.
- Not That I would know.
- I'm not even good.
I'm not very good at smoking pot anyway.
I'm just not good at it.
- I'm not at, I don't smoke anything.
I'm a singer, but it's,
I can't imagine your first
time and then you're-
- Oh wow, man.
- You were probably, that
person was probably like
what is wrong with her?
She was like 10...
- Yeah. (Andie laughs)
- 20, wait, can you give me that back?
Where was I?
- I had to do that once,
one time because the machine broke.
- Oh dear.
- And I panicked.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] And she wasn't stoned.
- It was like doing long-
Exactly, and I was completely fine.
- I used to count back change in my sleep,
I'm telling you, it was-
- We used to do a lot of
things before technology.
Like I knew numbers, like I could call
I knew everyone's phone number.
I don't know anyones.
- I know it's terrifying now.
- Yeah.
- You don't know people's
telephone numbers-
- It's so terrifying.
- I can remember my
original telephone number.
- [Kelly] Me too
- From growing up.
- 8 1 7
- Whoa.
- [Kelly] I know, well-
- [Andie] Yeah, okay.
- It was, I know we're
a different generation.